[Música]
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález comenzó el
mes de octubre muchos países de américa
latina ya han cumplido su primer mes de
apertura tras el confinamiento debido a
la pandemia del cob y 19 países como
argentina continúan con un aparente
confinamiento que tiene muchas
excepciones sin embargo los números de
casos siguen aumentando en la mayoría de
los países también siguen aumentando los
fallecidos y también las economías están
seriamente afectadas por esta crisis y
están tratando de sobrellevar la
situación qué fue lo que pasó en américa
latina' se salió de control la situación
este análisis
babel también para hacer balance es
nuestro tema en el debate de france 24
pero primero veamos algunas cifras para
ponernos en contexto américa latina y el
caribe están registrando al día de hoy 9
millones 778 mil 867 casos confirmados
todos los países en conjunto esto
representa el 27 punto 0 2 por ciento de
los casos a nivel mundial
las víctimas mortales ya superan las 358
mil 705 y solo el día de hoy fueron
reportados hasta el momento del cierre
de la redacción para empezar el programa
al aire 72 1930 casos una cifra que
representa un incremento del 1 por
ciento si lo comparamos con los últimos
7 días este es el listado de los 10
países con la mayor cantidad de casos en
nuestro continente y en la región de
américa latina que es la que vamos a
debatir y vamos a discutir la lista la
lidera brasil y le siguen en su orden
colombia perú argentina méxico chile
ecuador bolivia panamá y república
dominicana
todos estos datos fueron publicados el
día de hoy por el banco interamericano
de desarrollo
para analizar este tema hemos invitado a
ana morice ella es médica epidemióloga
ex viceministra de salud de costa rica y
también es consultora internacional se
une a este debate desde la ciudad de san
josé y también está con nosotros
francisco de sierra él es experto en
políticas de salud pública y ex
subdirector de la organización
panamericana de la salud nos acompaña
desde la ciudad de mexico ustedes
también pueden ser parte de este debate
todos sus comentarios y las redes
sociales las pueden dejar en nuestra
cuenta en instagram y en twitter y
también en facebook arroba france guión
al piso no france24 en el piso s y
arroba sant y luego a la etiqueta es
numeral el debate efe 24 pues ya tenemos
el tema tenemos a los invitados y quiero
comenzar entonces con anna en la ciudad
de san josé en costa rica cuál es el
balance que usted hace de estos meses de
pandemia para la región de américa
latina
tuvimos confinamiento cierres totales la
mayoría de los países están ya en un
proceso de apertura que lleva un mes y
su país costa rica en un momento fue uno
de los abanderados
dos de los más admirados por el manejo
que le estaba dando a la pandemia y
finalmente pues esta perspectiva cambió
con el paso de los meses que pasó
nosotros pensábamos que américa latina
ha sido beneficiar del conocimiento y la
experiencia de europa y estábamos un
poco más esperanzados viendo como la
primera hora nos iba a afectar yo creo
que uno de los factores que hace que
impacto en gran medida a los países de
américa latina fue la inequidad
específicamente en costa rica nosotros
estábamos muy orgullosos
hasta junio donde realmente habíamos
podido contener la transmisión con muy
pocos casos sin embargo empezó esta
transmisión en áreas urbano marginales
en el área metropolitana en zonas muy
densamente pobladas
probablemente influenciada por migración
ilegal donde es muy difícil contenerla
porque son personas que no quieren que
las encuentren y que muchos de ellos son
jóvenes y tal vez no llegan a los
hospitales porque no están tan mal pero
si transmiten el virus eso mismo ocurrió
por ejemplo chile que fue un país
sumamente muy afectado
y no es casual que son estos países que
tienen la mayor inequidad en nuestros
países por ejemplo uruguay uruguay un
país que ha sido muy exitoso en el
manejo de la pandemia pero además de
situaciones de menor inequidad del
uruguay específicamente es un país con
una densidad poblacional muchísimo más
baja también la ubicación geográfica y
la migración o si hay una serie de
factores sociodemográficos que explican
por qué algunos países han sido más
afectados que otros y por supuesto
analizar los números teniendo
diferencias tan importantes en el testeo
y en la capacidad de los servicios para
poder diagnosticar los casos pues es
difícil estaríamos comparando manzanas
con naranjas como por ejemplo la
situación de nicaragua
que básicamente ellos no están testeando
solamente algunos pocos entonces tienen
muy pocos casos así que también para
poder analizar la situación de nuestros
países tenemos que entender cómo está
funcionando la vigilancia
la capacidad de los servicios para poder
atender a estas personas que se intentan
francisco en la ciudad de méxico- cuál
es su balance entonces de estos meses
anna destacaba la inequidad y también
las diferencias en los sistemas de salud
de los diferentes países y la
realización de las pruebas ya citaba
ella el caso de nicaragua comparándolo
con costa rica
gracias por la invitación santiago mucho
gusto doctora maurice nos vimos en la
mañana en otra conferencia ahora
coincidimos nuevamente creo que aquí hay
una serie de situaciones que nos
demuestra una fragilidad de los sistemas
de salud en américa latina y el caribe
creo que además de todas las inequidades
que esta región de las américas nuestra
tiene y que si hay cinturones de miseria
hay gente que vive en condiciones de
vulnerabilidad muy importante debemos de
recordar que la fragilidad que han
demostrado nuestros sistemas de salud es
muy importante ósea
en pocos países tienen por arriba del 6%
cerca de 6% de lo que recomienda la oms
como el gasto público en salud esto
quiere decir que si ahorita andamos en
un 54 6% muchas veces está por arriba de
la mitad el gasto de bolsillo esto
quiere decir que la población está
pagando de su bolsillo la mitad de lo
que se gasta en salud en algunos países
mientras los países no inviertan de
manera importante en su salud en sus
sistemas de salud en fortalecer la
infraestructura en contratar más
personal en ampliar la cobertura vamos a
seguir viendo problemas de este tipo
como decía la doctora maurice y había
una situación de que pensábamos que
porque ya venía la o la tarde nos íbamos
a poder preparar y vamos a estar listos
pero no fue así creo que él
la demanda también de equipo de
protección personal de ventiladores de
camas que eeuu y principalmente en
europa ya se empezaron a tener
impidieron que ese equipo llegara
también con la oportunidad a méxico oa
otros países en la región porque además
de que se obstruyeron las cadenas
logísticas desde la producción hasta los
barcos y los aviones para llegar a otros
lugares se encarecieron también entonces
esa escasez y por lo menos 69 países
pusieron obstrucciones para la
exportación de equipos y equipo de
protección personal a otros países
anna uno de los factores que llamó la
atención y ha llamado la atención a lo
largo de estos meses en américa latina
es que muchos países comenzaron una un
confinamiento temprano si todo el caso
de colombia por ejemplo el caso del
ecuador y perú que llamaron a sus
ciudadanos a quedarse en sus casas y
paralizaron la economía todo esto para
poderse preparar para la llegada
la pandemia ya como tal y el aumento de
los casos pero vemos que países como
perú como ecuador no podemos dejar de
lado esas imágenes del puerto de
guayaquil con los cuerpos tirados en las
calles y colombia que está con una tasa
de contagio muy alta esta estrategia ya
después de estos meses si funcionó no
funcionó porque fue un punto de
señalamiento para los para las
autoridades
y precisamente nosotros tuvimos esa
discusión con colegios que han estado en
los consejos asesores de covite en los
países de américa y pensamos que el
martillo famoso estrategia del martillo
y la danza en américa
funcionó inicialmente retomó de nuevo lo
que lo que comentaba de la pobreza en
nuestros países y la alta densidad
poblacional que existe y también lo que
el doctor becerra comentaba sobre la
fragilidad de algunos sistemas de
servicios y servicios de salud donde hay
personas que transmiten el virus que no
son atendidas que se quedan en sus casas
obviamente eso por más confinamiento y
por más martillo que haya transmiten el
virus en sus casas y en las casas
este cercanas y el otro factor que me
parece importante de porque esa
estrategia del confinamiento fue muy
compleja y realmente no tuvo los efectos
que esperábamos son factores de tipo
económico por ejemplo en alemania que
han sido un país exitoso ellos
mantuvieron salarios y dieron bonos a
personas que se quedaron sin trabajo
pero en países como los nuestros donde
las personas pierden su trabajo y tienen
tienen que comer
y no tienen una ayuda del estado también
que les pueda permitir mantener el
confinamiento pues salen a las calles y
maliense incrementan la informalidad
este porque las personas quedan
desempleadas y no pueden quedarse dentro
de sus casas esperando que lleguen a
tocarle la puerta entonces yo creo que
es esa estrategia del off down que tal
vez en europa funcionó mejor porque las
personas tenían las condiciones para
quedarse en sus casas y lo otro también
importante es que hay casas de casas por
ejemplo acá en costa rica mucho de la
transmisión que fue en junio julio que
se fue para arriba eran en cuarterías o
sea eran personas en condición irregular
que vivían en condiciones de saneamiento
básico
esencial que dormían unas con otras
entonces el lock down
como se explica y más bien es un riesgo
que al centro de la casa en estas
condiciones el entonces yo creo que esos
factores sociodemográficos y
socioeconómicos también de la población
y también obviamente la capacidad del
estado para poder dar una respuesta no
sólo de los servicios de salud sino
también al problema del desempleo
francisco le preguntaban a por este
confinamiento temprano para prepararnos
pero vemos países como por ejemplo
argentina que sigue con un confinamiento
a un precio económico y social altísimo
sobre todo sabiendo las condiciones
económicas en las que argentina ha
tenido que enfrentar esta situación y
caso por ejemplo venezuela que tiene una
una restricción de 7 días las personas
pueden salir y tiene otros 7 días que
tienen que estar en confinamiento ya van
más de seis meses en confinamiento
algunos países van a empezar a enfrentar
la segunda ola y estos países siguen
confinados esperando la ola de la
primera etapa que se puede esperar
entonces en esos casos
creo que aquí está y hay ciertas cosas
que tenemos que considerar
creo que ya conocemos mucho de la parte
preventiva para evitar el contagio de
persona a persona ahí creo que tenemos
la oportunidad de establecer un retorno
a las actividades económicas de una
manera gradual con todas las cuestiones
de seguridad con mascarillas caretas y
la limpieza de manos que es
importantísimo creo que el análisis de
cada tipo de comercio de fábrica de
maquiladora que haya se tendrá que hacer
al fin de proteger a los empleados y a
los usuarios de esos lugares creo que sí
es importante considerar esto y tratar
de utilizar las mejores medidas de
prevención al fin de poder retornar poco
a poco la actividad económica creo que
se ha demostrado que el uso continuo de
mascarilla lavado de manos el gel
alcoholado tienen un impacto positivo
pero que nos está pasando de que la
gente empieza a salir y siente que ya
después de un confinamiento prolongado
que lo que necesita es la fiesta
necesita ir a jugar es que necesita la
tertulia y muchas veces no se enciende
cubrebocas sin la sana distancia que
debe haber entre unos y otros y creo que
en ese sentido no estamos como
ciudadanía como comunidades apoyando
todo lo que viviéramos en muchos en
muchos países y ahí si yo no me pongo el
cubrebocas nadie se lo va a poner por mí
si yo no me lavo las manos nadie se las
va a lavar por mí pues yo también tengo
que tener una responsabilidad personal y
en mi familia la protejo protejo a mi
comunidad protejo mi país
en ese en ese orden de ideas francisco
estaríamos hablando entonces de la
disciplina ciudadana haciendo un poco de
balance de lo que hemos visto en estos
meses
uruguay por ejemplo fue un país que ha
sido reconocido a nivel internacional
por el manejo que le ha dado a la crisis
y uno de los puntos que destacaban era
precisamente la disciplina de los
ciudadanos de los uruguayos y que creen
en lo que están diciendo las
instituciones lo mismo decían de costa
rica en el momento en que también era
uno de los países que tenía una poca
incidencia del virus nos faltó
disciplina nos sigue faltando disciplina
entonces de acuerdo a lo que usted nos
dice cómo reforzar ese mensaje dentro de
los ciudadanos porque el gobierno ya no
puede hacer más por nosotros las
autoridades ya no pueden hacer más por
nosotros y el autocuidado es el que vale
claro totalmente yo creo que aquí es
conciencia y disciplina y también
obviamente nosotros los latinoamericanos
y los caribeños nos gusta la fiesta nos
gusta
y en la salsa que ya está internacional
la cumbia etcétera pero
debemos de ser conscientes y no es lo
mismo la reacción que tenemos desde el
américa latina ante lo que nos pide el
gobierno y las autoridades que hagamos a
lo que por ejemplo tienen en asia que no
no les importa que los estén siguiendo a
través de un dispositivo móvil para
asegurarse que no están contagiando
entonces aquí lo veríamos como una
intrusión de la libertad nadie le haría
caso mientras que en otros países es una
cuestión también cultural de aceptar
cómo las autoridades pueden tomar
decisiones por el bien común y creo que
en salud pública es el tipo de
actividades que tenemos que tener son
decisiones por el bien común y creo que
el uso mandatorio de cubrebocas lavado
de manos y fortalecer las medidas de
prevención son importantísimas y tener
conciencia de que nosotros tenemos una
corresponsabilidad esto no es algo que
haya sido problema o causado por los
gobiernos lo que sí es problema es
quizás en algunos casos una mala acción
o toma de decisiones por algunos
gobiernos
retrasaron las actividades o que no han
invertido lo suficiente en detección de
casos en tratamiento oportuno que es
diferente no son dos cosas que hay que
separar pero como comunidad si tenemos
una responsabilidad y la parte cultural
también juega y también como el gobierno
las autoridades están pasando el mensaje
de la ciudadanía usted ya toca un tema
justo me lleva a mi siguiente pregunta
que la tenía para hacérsela a anna y es
sobre el papel de los gobiernos el
balance que podemos hacer de la forma
como comunicaron la situación la las
decisiones a los ciudadanos vimos todo
tipo de maneras de manejar la situación
en brásil muy polémico lo que hizo
bolsonaro en méxico también muchos
criticaron al presidente andrés manuel
lópez obrador y otros criticaron por
ejemplo el presidente del salvador por
haberse ido demasiado la extremo ya y
tratar de anticipar la llegada del virus
y haber mandado a los salvadoreños a sus
casas antes de que la situación fuera
muy grave que piensa usted al respecto
yo coincido totalmente incluso en el
caso costa rica afortunadamente ahora la
curva más bien va a por lo menos está en
una meseta o va bajando y las
hospitalizaciones de cuidado intensivo
tiene una tendencia descendente que
esperamos se mantenga y ahí una de esas
explicaciones es la autogestión del
riesgo que nosotros apostamos un poco a
eso dado el incremento de la curva
porque no podíamos mantener el
confinamiento
y aunque es muy difícil creo que tal vez
no al 100% pero un porcentaje importante
de la población lo ha aceptado y ahora
uno ve las personas con mascarillas
cuidándose a través de licenciamiento
obviamente también él
ha habido un cambio en estrategia de
comunicación creíamos y pienso que
estuvo atinado que el mensaje también
era un mensaje muy negativo era todos
los días hay tantos muertos hay tantos
casos y la gente lo que estaba esperando
un número entonces lo que se replanteó y
obviamente no es fácil es más incluso
aspectos de tipo antropológico como
realmente cambiar las conductas de la
población no solamente un mensaje del
número de casos y número de muertos que
todos los días eran repetitivo y que ya
la persona lo oía como odio ver sino más
bien de cuáles son las medidas y cuál es
la responsabilidad de acuerdo también a
las diferentes categorías de riesgo
ahora eso no es suficiente o sea que uno
apueste a que las personas sean
responsables de su propio riesgo no es
suficiente el estado también tiene una
función
algo tal vez relevante es no solamente
el estado nacional el estado como como
país sino también el gobierno local y
acá se le solicitó a cada una de las
municipalidades que hiciera un plan y
ellos por ejemplo son responsables de
velar por el cumplimiento de los
protocolos en los restaurantes de velar
también por los parques y si ellos
deciden que el parque no se abre y las
playas nos no se abren el gobierno local
es responsable de definirlo porque si no
pues va a sufrir un castigo digámoslo
así yo creo que hay que hacer un balance
entre convencimiento pero también se
requieren regulaciones y se requieren
este multas también este se mantiene por
ejemplo descripción vehicular o sea
algunas cosas que se han probado ser
efectivas se mantienen pero hay que
apostar a la responsabilidad y a la
gestión del riesgo de individual y local
también del gobierno local y francisco
cuál es su opinión en torno a este tema
a la gestión de los gobiernos y a la
comunicación que hubo entre gobiernos y
los ciudadanos
y como manejaron la situación porque ya
lo hacíamos vimos todo tipo de
reacciones
así es tanto yo creo que creo que ha
habido de todo como como en botica
decimos que hemos tenido preside
presidentes que han tomado la iniciativa
que han sido proactivos en la
comunicación con la ciudadanía mientras
que otros han ido minimizando la
problemática
haciendo burla de la misma y hemos visto
las consecuencias en bada en muchos
países creo que ahí está el lo mejor es
tener las evidencias para la mejor toma
de decisiones y creo que eso es algo que
nos ha faltado en esta en esta pandemia
ver y aprender de lo que ya otros países
habían hecho con muy buenos resultados y
que si requería más inversión pero están
salvando vidas están salvando casos que
se hospitalizan y tenemos el caso por
ejemplo de nueva zelanda el caso de
japón que ha sido muy exitosos
es tenemos otros casos como los que
tenemos en américa latina con
millones de casos ya con este cientos
miles de cientos de muertes y que eso a
la larga va a traer un impacto en muchas
familias por la cantidad de ingreso
familiar que se va a perder porque si el
padre que trabajaba ya no lo va a poder
hacer y la norma no lo hacía desde que
va a vivir esa familia empresas que van
a perder a trabajadores porque
fallecieron esos trabajadores por
contagio entonces esto va a ser un esto
no es una carrera de sprint esto es una
carrera que nos va a llevar tiempo en
tratar de corregir lo que ha venido
pasando en que se requiere más inversión
en corregir el rumbo de los sistemas de
salud y también en apoyar a la parte de
la economía para apoyar a los más pobres
a los más necesitados y aquí está esta
economía nos está afectando con ya
países que en la región con menos 12%
del pib y cualquier recuperación que
haya hoy tener el producto interno bruto
lleva con un hándicap entonces de aquí a
que podamos llegar a lo que estábamos
de la pandemia va a costar trabajo y eso
va a impactar en todavía y vamos a ver
una cantidad de empresas que van a
cerrar y van a quebrar por la falta de
estímulos por la falta de apoyos de como
decía la doctora ilustraba naciones
alemania y en otros países y eso y eso
se va a ver reflejado francisco en otras
áreas como el aumento de la pobreza el
incremento en las divisiones sociales
esa brecha tecnológica que también quedó
en evidencia con el tema de la de las
escuelas en casa muchos alumnos no
tenían cómo estudiar porque simplemente
no tienen acceso a internet y no tienen
ni siquiera los equipos para poderlo
hacer
estamos viendo en este momento en europa
en la segunda ola el rebrote vemos otra
vez a francia con problemas de
incrementos de casos 18.000 casos en las
últimas 24 horas alemania también con
una un ascenso en los casos españa por
supuesto con también con esta
politización del tema de las medidas en
la comunidad de madrid' estamos viendo
otra vez el espejo por la ventana
en nuestras casas que hacer en américa
latina entonces porque lo que está
sucediendo allí puede volvernos a pasar
a na
sí yo creo que algo muy importante es
entender cuáles son las características
de los casos en esta segunda ola también
en la primera pero hablemos de la
situación de europa porque algo
interesante por ejemplo es que hemos
visto un incremento muy acelerado de
casos pero no así por ahora de las
hospitalizaciones y de los muertos esa
obviamente esa curva va después pero
bueno pero no no ha sido este en este
momento problemático y lo que lo que se
reporta por lo menos en alemania que
conozco es que los casos son más en
gente joven y son el resultado de
fiestas de reuniones familiares de gente
que ya perdió digamos el temor a la
pandemia y que relajó las medidas
precisamente lo que estábamos hablando
de lo importante de la gestión de la
responsabilidad de cada uno pero si son
personas jóvenes que además como dice el
doctor besser ya están cansadas ya no
quieren más encierro necesitan
socializar
saben que si se enferman probablemente
no van a tener la gravedad que va a
tener una persona adulto mayor o que
tiene una persona con factores de riesgo
y relajan las medidas que es lo que está
ocurriendo en estos países de europa son
más en población
este joven sin embargo eso es ahora pero
esas personas jóvenes están en contacto
también con personas adultas mayores
están en contacto con personas con
factores de riesgo y obviamente
ahora lo tal vez los hospitales y las
defunciones no está mal pero llegará si
no nos cuidamos y si no con tenemos esa
esa segunda bola y lo otro que por
supuesto preocupa para los países de
europa que están en este momento es que
ahora viene el invierno ya está en otoño
pero llegará el invierno y el invierno
no necesariamente porque el virus que es
estacional yo creo que es otra discusión
es más desde el punto de vista
conductual o sea las familias se quedan
dentro de las casas este y sabemos que
la probabilidad de contagio de contagio
es mucho más baja afuera en la calle al
aire libre donde las personas pueden
tener distanciamiento pero si viene el
invierno y las personas por condiciones
climatológicas no pueden salir y ahí la
tasa de transmisión es muy alta pues va
a ser muy peligroso para los países de
europa así que esa segunda ola deben
contenerla antes de que llegue un
invierno más fuerte es que ese
precisamente ana es el temor porque en
la parte del extremo sur de suramérica
nosotros estamos transmitiendo desde
bogotá pero chile uruguay argentina y en
cierto modo brasil y perú están
terminando el invierno bueno ya están ya
estamos en primavera el verano está a la
vuelta de la esquina el escenario es
completamente opuesto y nos vamos a
enfrentar a la segunda ola entonces es
muy interesante ver esa perspectiva para
américa del sur francisco
evitar lo que está pasando en europa que
justo está saliendo del verano donde la
gente se fue de fiesta y se fue a las
playas y suramérica está por empezar el
verano así es y esto trae riesgos en
todos sentidos como bien lo decía la
doctora creo que ahí es en dónde
en la apertura gradual tiene que irse
dando por muchos sentidos por salud
mental por la parte económica por las
necesidades de las familias etcétera
pero creo que hay manera de hacerlo de
una con una prevención bien cuidada con
con todas las medidas de higiene y
preventivas que ya conocemos y que no
son nuevas ya después de tantos meses
que estamos viviendo con la pandemia ya
sabemos exactamente qué es lo que
tenemos que hacer pero este estos
ejemplos que es de lo que está
sucediendo en europa en estas ciudades y
en estos países que ya vimos que les
pegó fuerte y que ahora le está
volviendo a pegar lo que ha pasado en
algunas ciudades de eeuu que tuvieron un
incremento de un mes a otro de 25 por
ciento de casos en la detección
creo que nos debe de alertar y alertar a
los jóvenes los jóvenes son quizás como
decía la doctora y los que tienen se
pueden infectar y no les no les importa
porque muchos van a ser asintomáticos me
siento muy bien no pasa nada dar me dio
un catarro y lo confunda en un catarro
con con un inicio de recurrir pero
cuántos de ellos se están infectando qué
terminan en el hospital y así sean
deportistas y se cuiden mucho están
terminando con problemas crónicos como
una fibrosis pulmonar y hay muchos casos
que van a terminar con secuelas y que
van a requerir atención médica
prolongada por el resto de sus vidas y
creo que esa parte no les termina de
hacer clic y esa es una parte que los
jóvenes tienen que considerar de que
ellos también se pueden enfermar y de
que también pueden morir si tienen
obesidad si son diabéticos hipertensos
porque hay muchos jóvenes que ya son así
van a tener un mal pronóstico pero
jóvenes incluso jóvenes deportistas
están terminando con la fibrosis
pulmonar y aún no sabemos todas las
secuelas que la comida pueda dejar a los
pacientes que están informados y que por
afortunadamente salvan la vida pero que
van a tener muchas secuelas a futuro
importante hacer énfasis en eso doctor
francisco becerra me quedan ya pocos
minutos para cerrar el programa quiero
terminar con un escenario a futuro
cuando
la esperada vacuna entra en circulación
y se ha comprobado su efectividad
y pueda empezar a ser distribuida
tenemos una región muy complicada
sabemos de los temas de violencia de
inseguridad las mafias es donde se
adultera todo tipo de productos
las vacunas van a ser unos bienes
preciadísimo que la gente hará lo que
sea con tal de acceder a una dosis para
poderse vacunar contra el joven 19 como
de ustedes escenario vana
precisamente hoy el doctor besser
estuvimos en esa discusión con varios
países y acá yo creo que hay una doble
complicación uno que las coberturas de
la vacunación de las vacunas de rutina
de las vacunas que están en los
calendarios de vacunación han bajado y
entonces se espera para el año entrante
poder hacer un esfuerzo para poder
remontar las pero por otro lado tenemos
la vacuna famosa que estamos todos
anhelando de coronavirus que no va a
alcanzar para todos y tenemos un recurso
humano que es el recurso humano que es
limitado y que como decía también el
doctor bcra los servicios de salud la
vacunación es un programa prioritario
pero bueno nunca es suficiente los
recursos humanos así que va a tener que
multiplicarse el próximo año para poder
remontar las coberturas de enfermedades
que no queremos que surjan porque todas
vamos a tener más complicación con
enfermedades por brotes de enfermedades
prevenibles que ya no se controlaron
adecuadamente por baja en las coberturas
y por
una de coronavirus logísticamente
también hay algunos retos países
pequeños como costa rica puede ser que
recibimos que recibamos un tipo de
vacuna pero países grandes van a tener
no sé tres tipos de vacuna cada una con
con diferentes formas de presentación
con diferentes logísticas de
almacenamiento de cadena de frío así que
creo que para el sistema de salud el año
entrante va a ser un año complejo porque
es remontar en el mejor sentido desde el
punto de vista de que vamos a tener
vacuna pero es remontar lo que lo que lo
que nos atrasamos este año más entrar
con una vacuna nueva donde también hay y
lo hemos estado discutiendo uno piensa
que todo el mundo y a lo mejor si
américa latina es un país que cree mucho
en vacunación está esperando la vacuna y
se va anglo mirar para que la vacuna
pero también tenemos renuencia a la
vacunación y hay personas que
que no querrán vacunarse y algunas de
esas pueden ser personas que son de
riesgo incluso hasta personal de salud o
personas
-este adultos que no querrán vacunarse
porque desconfían de la vacuna americano
es un país con una renuencia tan alta
como por ejemplo los países de europa
pero europa se enfrentará también a ese
desierto que no es solamente la vacuna
esté ahí hay un sentimiento y obviamente
esta crisis nos golpea a todos en la
salud mental desde estar opuesto a todo
ósea brack y bueno y en mi país ahora
hay brotes de violencia haciendo sondeos
que es por la mascarilla por el gobierno
por los impuestos por todo y al final se
junta y es claro bomba de tiempo y en
ese contexto viene la vacuna del color
habidos así que es un escenario
esperanzador pero creo que enfrenta
también importantes retos francisco su
conclusión con este tema a futuro y con
este escenario que vemos en américa
latina pues de pronto que el virus se
quede más tiempo de lo esperado en esta
región logró escribir se va a quedar
y vamos a tener que aprender a vivir con
él y vamos a ver algunos picos
estacionarios algunos picos que vayan a
estar pasando pero creo que por fortuna
hay muchos proyectos de vacunas que se
están estudiando en este momento
entonces se abre la posibilidad para que
varias vacunas que demuestren su
eficacia y su seguridad puedan llegar a
la población en general
eso es 12 que también va a haber una
cuestión de definición de poblaciones y
de ccoo por estrategias de vacunación va
a ser quienes vamos a vacunar primero
personal de salud adultos mayores niños
esa es una decisión que cada gobierno
tendrá que tomar pero creo que va a
haber recomendaciones muy puntuales por
parte de organización mundial de la
salud
y también considerar que como decía la
doctora anna tenemos muchos problemas a
veces rechazo a la vacuna francisco
lamento cortarlo se me acaba el tiempo a
los dos muchísimas gracias por habernos
acompañado en el debate de france 24 de
ustedes muchas gracias por la sintonía
siga con nosotros
[Música]